Hey, good morning everybody.
Sorry about that. I had to, um, check Connie in there.
Everybody here in my house is really, really sick,
except me.
I mean, they are really, really sick.
So we're gonna be going to InstaCare after this.
Uh, but I hope everybody's doing good.
See if I can find the chat over here.
Uh, gimme just a minute. Um, maybe, uh, GIA Pne.
Can you guys go into the messenger rooms, into WhatsApp?
Give people the link to sign up for this call.
I know there's no, um, I know there's no automatic,
uh, join link anymore.
Um, but if you could just please,
please give people the link to, um, join this call.
Can you guys do that for me?
Sure. And then check in with coffee too
and let me know if he's got that done for me
to show on the call.
Alright, so good morning everybody.
Welcome to the local newsletter hour.
Um, first of all, how many of you got the, uh,
webinar registration this morning?
Did anybody get the webinar registration? Time to chat?
Let me know if you got the webinar registration. Good.
So, um, surely you did.
'cause that's how you joined the call, right?
Uh, we're still trying to figure out this Zoom webinar.
I don't know if I'm sold on it or not.
Um, you know,
on the meeting we usually get over a hundred people.
Uh, but this one here, uh, I'm at like 55 people right now.
So, uh, we will see if we can get everybody, um,
on this call here in a minute.
But here's the good news.
You may have noticed who did that registration come from?
Did anybody see that? By chance?
Who did that registration come from?
One of my favorite actors of all time.
It came from Zoom. But here's the thing.
Pacino went
and wrote, uh, that webinar registration Pacino did.
So my new open Claw bought,
which I'm gonna talk about that for a minute.
And you're going, what does that have
to do with the local newsletter?
Oh, I'm gonna tell you, right?
My open cloud bot went and used a browser control.
It actually logged into Zoom.
It went into the actual webinar.
It clicked on the webinar, it opened up the email.
It found the reminder. It took the reminder.
I said, here's the notes for the call today.
It created the notes.
It went in there, it created the reminder,
and then it went through and it updated, uh, the emails
that go out for the replay.
And then the people that missed the call, it did all of
that automatically.
So what you guys wanna do is you probably wanna go back
and look at that email
because it came from Pacino, which is my, uh, open clock.
Alright? So what in the world is this?
Well, I'm gonna talk about this
and first, let me kind of bridge this together.
This is the reason why this relates to the local newsletter.
What if I told you this weekend that, uh, my open claw,
and if you don't know about this,
we're gonna talk about this here in a minute.
Uh, it's the most advanced AI
automation I've ever seen in my life.
Went out there and it's still doing it.
And it's keeping an eye on anything happening
relevant to Summerland.
Any article that gets created, any new story
that gets created, it's letting me know when
something's hot or whatever.
And then it's putting it into a media bank.
It's putting it into a memory bank.
And then what it does is not only is it out there just
finding things on its own,
but storing it in the memory bank.
Then it turned around and said, Hey, uh,
do you want me to create an article?
I said, yeah, please go create an article. Guess what it is?
Trained to take that link, go pop it into Letterman
and create the article.
So then it left the West Valley shoutouts.
I'll show you this article here in a minute.
It left the West Valley shoutouts logo,
uh, inside the article.
So then, you know, I told her, I said, Hey, look at
that article and do me a favor.
Go create an image, okay? And plug that into the article.
I don't think it was a great image,
but it was a hell of a start.
And not only that, it took the article,
it opened up the side, it went and added it to the archive.
It added it to the newsfeed.
It, it stopped it from being indexed.
Uh, I told it, don't add it to the newsletter queue.
Then I said, how did the keywords look?
It said, the keywords are good. It saved everything.
It published it. And boom, I was laying in bed and I went
and I opened up the archives and I saw my article there.
Is everybody hearing this right now? Type in the chat.
Let me know if you get this on a scale of one out
of 10 folks, the future is here.
Now, I'll come back to the newsletter for a minute,
but everybody's been blowing me up all weekend
because they know that we are
here on ground technology.
Now, I'm gonna tell you guys right now,
and I'm gonna be upfront,
and I'm gonna be honest, I have not been excited with ai.
Obviously, we implemented AI inside
of Member Offerman Letterman, everything else to the point
where, you know, it creates headlines and pages and logos.
Okay, cool. But I have not been
as excited as everybody else.
I'm not out there running events.
I'm not out there and I'm posting on my wall about look at
what nano bonano does, like, da da da.
I have not been excited with it. And here's the reason why.
And I set it years ago.
I set it up on stage when I was still with my old partner.
I said, right now, for the next couple years,
the world is gonna build this brain.
Did anybody hear me say this?
The world is gonna build this brain
and it's gonna train this brain with chat.
GPT and Claude and Gemini
and all these AI platforms is training the brain.
Does anybody remember me talking about this? Years ago?
I told you we're gonna train the brain for years, okay?
And in this time, this brain is gonna learn how to do things
and it's gonna be very, very unstable.
And they're gonna be in beta on a lot of things.
And it's not something you're gonna be able to count on,
and you gotta have patience with it.
Okay? So that's what's been
happening for the last few years.
The, the world has been training this brain,
and now this brain is really, really intelligent.
So for the first time ever, you know,
when people got all excited about vibe coding
and everything else where you just type a prompt
and it creates the software, I was not excited with that.
I'm like, wait a minute. If people have to sit here
and say, okay, but can you make the UI blue?
Okay? Can you add that box? Okay, okay.
I'm, I'm smart enough to know that, look, if people have
to sit there and type those commands, then there's,
there should be some other smarter technology
that would do all that for you.
It, it would make sense, right?
If you, if you have to be the one saying, okay, I want you
to create a side ua, okay?
I want you to move the buttons, right?
You don't have a coding background,
you don't have a developer background.
So even typing a prompt doesn't make sense to me, right?
Especially after they're building software for 15 years.
What did make sense was a smarter technology
that would do all that stuff for you, right?
So instead of you being the brain
and typing things in, there would be a smarter brain
that has been trained for the last three years
or whatever that would do all that for you.
I actually talked about this during one
of my mastermind calls, and that day has come.
So AI is not just a brain now.
It's got eyes, it's got ears, it's got arms, it's got legs,
it's actually doing things for you.
Does everybody understand this? Now, I'm excited.
Up to this point, you did not see me teach you anything
about vibe coding or creating slides or doing nothing.
We, we played with the AI avatars for a while, you know,
using hey gen and, and, uh, the 11 labs, whatever.
But that wasn't where, it just wasn't there, right?
So I haven't really been excited this weekend,
this week I got really, really excited.
So lemme kind of break this down.
And like I said, uh, we have spent lots
of money over the past week, uh,
and what we're doing is we're creating skills for you.
Okay? So, uh, for the next two weeks, I'm getting ready
to create a shadow program.
Now, it's up to you if you wanna join or not. Okay?
Uh, everybody right now,
if you can put this link in the chat, you can go to open
or you can go to Chad nicely.com/open clock.
Can you guys go get that guide real quick?
Chad nicely.com/open.
Now we know for a fact it's going to create articles
for you over and over and over and over.
I don't think you would ever want something
to put out a newsletter without your say,
but I believe I, well, I know for a fact
that we can create newsletters
and we could put it in a draft status.
But guys, this is your community man.
This is your multimillion dollar check.
You don't wanna screw that up, right?
So I really, really believe that you need
to have the final set.
But what we're doing is for the next two weeks, we're going
to keep training on these skills
and everybody that sees the value in what we're doing
and is excited with this technology
and understands, okay, this is where AI starts.
I invite you to participate in the Shadow program. Okay?
Now, the last time I did a shadow program, I had 15 people
that watched me build course route.
We built it in a month, right?
So I'm still pretty proud of that.
Um, and they paid 9 97
because the technology is not where it needs to be.
It's in beta, it's rough.
It's, I'm gonna tell you right now guys, they ain't there,
but we're there at the ground stages, okay?
'cause I promised my mastermind
that we are gonna jump aboard AI like they've
never seen before.
Alright? So because of that, I've cut the price in half.
So if you wanna hang out with us at least for two weeks,
every single day we're gonna record the session.
It's gonna be about a two hour session.
Uh, then feel free
and we're gonna help you get set up with your VPS.
We're gonna help you get open claw installed.
We're gonna do it in a, in a VPS.
So that is in a safe environment.
You're not going to install it on your system.
We'll talk about that here in a minute, okay?
And, and if you wanna learn the very,
very best in AI technology, automations
and everything else, then you'll see a link
for the open cloth shadow intensive at the bottom
below that guide.
Okay? So go through the guide
and if you're like, okay, you know what?
I understand this, I understand why Chad's excited,
then jump aboard the shadow intensive.
We've already got some people coming in.
I wanna have about, again, 10 to 15 people
'cause of how hands on it is.
And so you'll watch us and here's the plan guys.
We have it where this thing's creating pop links.
I have it to where, uh, this thing's going into YouTube.
It is finding videos like it finds the
last newsletter, replay.
It grabs a transcript. It looks at it, it creates a copy.
It goes and clones our bridge page.
It changes the copy on the bridge page.
It replaces the video, it updates the timer,
it updates the URL, right?
So now our replay is all set up.
Uh, I already told you
that it's out there finding content for our newsletter.
It's writing the newsletters,
it's creating the webinar description, uh,
for this call here.
Um, and so we've already figured all that stuff out.
And so we're training it on these skills.
So we could just hand these skills over to you.
But now this week, this is
where I've saved some of the best for less.
If I shoot a video, I want it to take that video,
go into course Sprout, create the lesson,
create the descriptions, create the goal block to
where all I'm doing is shooting
videos just like I'm doing now.
And this thing is actually building a course piece by piece.
We're gonna figure that part out.
Uh, we're gonna figure out tags.
I want this thing to go and actually create a tag
and set up the integrations.
We're gonna figure out how
to send out a broadcast from my phone.
I talked to this thing on, uh, telegram.
So I'm gonna say, Hey, we need
to send out an email for this replay.
It's gonna create the email and say, yeah, perfect.
Send it and make sure you send it to the green.
Make sure you send it to a tag.
Guys, while I'm laying in bed, this thing is going to do all
of this for you.
Now, can everybody see the reason why I am
super, super excited?
So here's what happened,
and I want you guys to understand this.
Okay? So a lot
of people were out there when this thing first hit
and we were aware of it, man.
'cause we monitor everything as it's coming up.
My team is very, very trained on AI and everything else.
Uh, we saw this thing when it first hit. Alright?
So it come out as, uh, a claw bot, right?
So it comes out as Claude Bot, uh, Claude Anthropo,
the actual, uh, AI platform says, no, no, no, no, no.
We got a problem with that name.
So they turn around
and they try to change their name real quick.
They changed their GitHub,
they changed their Twitter handle.
And at that time, hackers came in
because there was a lot of, uh, a lot
of hype around that name.
And they took the name and then the hackers go out there
with the name or whatever, and they're doing all this crazy
stuff with cryptocurrency.
And that's a scam and everything else. So what happens?
Claude Bot takes the hit.
And so now all these people
that are just media whores on Facebook
and everything are out there saying, red alert, red alert.
Don't use Claude Bot. You're gonna thank me.
Read this post, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Even though it was a very, very credible project,
probably the very best technology we've ever seen, all
of a sudden everybody's like throwing mud at it, right?
Boom, boom, they're all throwing mud at it.
So now the whole entire focus becomes around drama
and this crypto platform and everything.
Well, me and my team saw through it.
We're like, Uhuh, continue full steam ahead.
We were already set up on a VPS.
We're like, okay, let's continue on the VPS.
We don't have to worry about it. We don't have crypto
there or anything else.
And then they turn around and they rebranded it to Mbot.
That lasted about a day.
And now finally they have settled on Open Claw. All right?
And I'm gonna tell you right now,
it is the very best technology I've ever seen.
The AI technology is finally where we need it to be.
Now it makes sense. Now I am invested this whole time.
I've just been monitoring things
and I've been watching everybody jump aboard these
bandwagons and go out there and do these summits
and these events and teach people this and that.
Meanwhile, it's changing every 10 minutes guys.
It is now going to not replace you in your business.
We're gonna talk about that. It's not gonna replace you,
but it's gonna do things for you
that you have struggled to do.
Now, when I say that I'm speaking about myself,
we have struggled to get the replays out there,
even though I got a team and everything.
They're busy building software and solving problems
and dealing with the Mastermind and everything.
And we don't always get the replay out there.
Well, guess what? Now we don't have to.
Now Open Claw is gonna make sure
that the replay gets created, right?
Uh, we've never been able to go in and fully grab the videos
and transcribe 'em and put 'em on the page.
Guess what? Now we don't have to.
Open Claw is gonna do all that for you. How about support?
Every single day I get a report on, here's all the things
that are going on in the support desk
that need your attention.
Boom, perfect. Open Claw gets to do all of that for us.
How about my Messenger? Now,
we haven't figured this one out yet, but we're going to.
I got people that are blowing up my Messenger right now.
Open Cloud. Open Cloud, open Cloud, open Cloud.
Just begging for that report that I just gave you guys.
Guess what? Open Cloud should be able to go in there
and monitor all those things.
We wanna do it from an I-P-A-I-P-I-A-P-I level.
And it should be able to respond for me.
It should be able to respond to my wall,
it can go through my email.
It can look for anybody that needs a link for this.
Needs a link for the replay, needs a link.
It is trained on all this stuff.
Now guys, I am so excited about this
that I gave my buddy Nick Coe.
I said, Hey, bring in those
four interns from UNLV.
Now I can work with him. He's been asking me for two years.
Chad, do you wanna do something with AI with me?
Like, look what I did. He spoke at my event.
You guys might remember this. I'm like,
Uhuh, I'm not sold on this.
I am not sold on it. It's not where it needs to be.
It's unstable. It will get there,
but it ain't there yet, folks.
It's there. So I told him last night, I said, you know what?
Go, go, go, go, go bring me those interns.
I'll have 'em work with my team,
and we will become the leader, uh, inside of ai.
'cause now I am absolutely sold.
You guys know I'm the very best to go out there
and teach anybody how to set up anything.
I take a very, very complicated process.
Make it very small, make it very compact.
And I get everybody the finish line.
And we're gonna be doing this.
So if you're a part of the Mastermind, get ready.
Um, because we're gonna do exactly like we set out
to do at the beginning of the year, right?
So does everybody understand
how it ties into the local newsletter?
Does everybody get this? Like the
things you're doing manually?
Remember, I don't want you giving up on this.
I, I want you to receive, I want you
to get gobbled up for millions of dollars.
I'm gonna keep telling you that I believe in
that wholeheartedly, okay?
But now let's let this thing do all the
work for you.
Does that make sense everybody? So time the chat here.
Let me know if you've got the guide.
Now, if you will, please do me a favor
and comment down below.
Once you get that guide, once you read the guide,
comment down below, tell me how excited you are.
I've gone through and documented everything inside
that guide, how to get set up with a VPS, how to add, how
to install claw Bot, how to go and, and add or open Claw.
How to add your API keys, how to set it up for voice, how
to set up your browser control, how to,
I I've done everything for you, right?
But there's a lot that we learned.
We spent a lot of money trying
to figure this technology out, trying
to figure how to install it.
We reinstalled it multiple times.
Like we took the bullet, we spent a lot of money
and basically gave you the shortcut.
So for instance, we spent a lot of time trying to figure out
how to go in the files and add, uh,
the different Claude models, right?
There's three different Claude models you're gonna use.
You might use Opus, you might use
Sonnet, you might use haku.
Like you might use all these different models
and you learn about all this stuff.
Well, we were doing all that manually,
but what we figured out was
that this damn thing could actually go
and just add it itself.
It can go, it can go take your API key
and just go set up all the files itself.
It took a while for us to learn this. Well, guess what?
I went and plugged it in the guide.
I'm like, here's your command.
Just tell it to go set up your API keys for you.
So now when you're talking to this thing, you can tell it,
Hey, do me a favor.
Go to, uh, Opus, right?
Because I need to, I need to train it. I need the brain.
I need the big dog to come out
and really learn this process, memorize it,
and then you can use one of the lower cheaper models
to actually running it every day.
Does that make sense? Type in the chat.
Let me know if that makes sense to you guys.
How do you get the guide? You go to chad.com/open
claw chad.com/open claw.
The link is in the chat. Does everybody got the guide?
Does everybody got the guide? This is the future folks.
This is the future.
My team, as we're going through this shadow intensive
and we're working with our members,
we've already identified right now we're using what's called
a browser control, which means open claws opening up the
browser and doing the steps just like you or your VA would.
But we're already looking at that going, dude,
our software is so badass.
Like we're gonna have it to where there's an API
to create a pop link.
We're gonna have it to where there's an API to create a tag.
We're gonna have it to where there's an API
to create a bridge page, to create a lead step
to create an article.
We're gonna API as many things we possibly can so
that you just create an audio file
and you just say, Hey, uh, Pacino, do me a favor.
Create me a pop link to the local newsletter hour
and uh, use chat i c.com.
We're gonna send 'em to local newsletter hour.com.
Do you understand? And it goes,
and we'll create the pop link not opening
up the browser or whatever.
No, it's just gonna access the API.
And guys, this is what's amazing about this,
and I've been talking about this for a while.
How many of you have ever heard me say
to use chat GPT perfectly?
You need to feed it.
Has anybody ever heard me say that you need to feed it?
Don't let it create its own thing. You gotta feed it.
Like give it somewhere to start with.
Don't start with a blank canvas.
Has anybody ever heard me talk about that for years? Right?
I've been saying that ever since Chad g PT came out.
You gotta go and feed it and let it rewrite it.
So it has your, your idea there.
It has your, your thought, it has your,
your thumbprint there, right?
Well, so guys, that's reactive. We've been reacting. Okay?
So Chad, GP t's been waiting for us.
And then it goes, and, and it, it,
it rewrites everything, right?
So we've been in a, in a reactive status, guys
with open claw, we're now proactive.
Does that make sense? We are now proactive.
Here's what happens. You are gonna train it on the skills
that you have in your business, okay?
So if you wanted to go check your emails, if you wanted
to respond to emails, right?
We'll talk about how you'll learn about this,
especially if you're in the shadow intensive.
You'll learn how to set up what's called an agent email.
And there's all kinds of cool stuff you're gonna do, right?
But as it learns your skills,
and we're just gonna take the, I I can't even tell you
how much we've spent in the past week.
We're just gonna take all the skills
that we have for our software.
We're gonna package it up
and we're gonna give it to you so that you can install it
as a plugin inside of your open claw, right?
So you're gonna be able to say, Hey, go create a pop link.
Hey, go create an article.
It will automatically start watching
for articles in your area.
Like all that stuff. We're gonna train it
for the next two weeks and then we're just gonna hand it
to you guys the skills.
Does that make sense to everybody?
So you wanna get this set up no matter what, right?
So, and like I said, during the shadow intensive,
we're gonna set all that stuff up for you.
We're gonna set up the VPS for you. The open clock.
Is it gonna be rough? Yeah, it's gonna be rough guys.
It's brand new technology in beta.
But we're gonna go, go, go, go, go.
Because from this point forward, I am in a thousand percent.
I am in. And we're gonna find a way
to implement everything inside of our software.
And we're gonna stay with ai. 'cause now we have our start.
So is there anybody
that's been feeling like you've been left behind,
you've been left out, you've been seeing all the posts,
you've been seeing the workshops,
you've been seeing everything and, and what they're doing
and all exciting and the events, everything.
Is there anybody that's feeling like behind
and like you're left out?
Type the chat. Let me know.
That's most of the people on this call.
Most of the people have been feeling behind
and you've been feeling like, oh man, I'm not,
I'm not creating apps with vibe coding.
I'm not creating so that it's okay.
I told you, I'll let you know when it is time.
How many of you heard me say that?
Don't worry about it right now. Let everybody tinker.
It is changing every day anyways.
It's not somewhere where you wanna start.
Now we got our starting point, now we're go, go, go.
Does that make sense? Does everybody get this? Now we are.
Go, go, go. For the first time ever.
I can honestly say that VAs are in trouble.
This, this technology here
can replace VAs,
where VAs are gonna let you down or whatever.
When this thing is trained, guys,
it ain't gonna let you down.
It's gonna go set up freaking replays for you.
Uh, during our intensive, you are gonna see me go,
I'm gonna start shooting YouTube videos so
that I can start putting YouTube videos out there.
And here's how to set up your VPS.
Here's how to set it up with Instagram.
Here's how to set or not Instagram, telegram.
Here's how to set it up with WhatsApp.
I'm gonna shoot as many of these little videos
as I possibly can, okay?
And the reason why is
because I wanna show you how this technology can now take
those videos, can cut it up,
can use platforms like Opus clip
or whatever, syndicate it out there to TikTok, Facebook,
Instagram, like all that stuff.
All that stuff automatically without me telling it.
So that's the difference guys. We're no longer reactive.
It's no longer a matter of Chad telling it.
It's going to learn your skills in your business.
What we're doing with our software,
the newsletter meant bird pop links, all
that stuff is gonna learn all that stuff.
And then what happens is it starts to learn your schedule.
For instance, it knows
that I'm on the local newsletter hour call right now.
And so what it knows is in about two hours,
because my calls are typically 90 minutes
that it's gonna go into Vimeo
because, uh, zoom automatically takes it places
it in Vimeo for us.
It's gonna go in there, it's gonna find the last
local newsletter hour.
It's gonna go drive, grab the transcript, transcribe it,
look at the notes, and go create that bridge page, plug the,
uh, replay video in there and everything else.
It knows that I'm on a call right now. It knows that, right?
And what I, what we're trying to do is figuring out how
to create a plugin so that that thing can be talking
to you while you're on the, while I'm on the call right now.
That thing can be going
through there and answering comments.
And not only that, it has access to SaaS onboard.
So what does that mean? Well, it can go into SaaS onboard.
If you say, Hey, I can't log into Letterman
or whatever, it can take your email, go in there
and reset your password or give you the credential.
Am I back?
Okay. I don't know what happened. We had a power surge here.
Sorry about that. That's crazy.
So apparently they can't help me
with power surges though, right?
The whole screens went black, the lights went out.
Everything went out, all right. Um, anyways,
what I was saying is, guys,
we're now leaving the reactive stage
and we're going to a proactive stage.
Okay? So once it learns your skills, right?
Once it learns all those things, all right?
It knows your business. It knows I got the
newsletter hour on Monday.
It knows I got the titanium tech call on Friday.
We're probably gonna put together an AI call now. Um, right?
But it knows those things
so it know it, it already knows what to do.
Uh, I'll see if I can share my screen here in a little bit.
When I woke up this morning, I said it said, Hey,
what are your top three priorities?
Here's how much you did in sales.
So it went and looked at the mint bird sales.
Here's how much you did in ad stats.
So we went and looked at our ad stats yesterday.
Here's your subscribers.
Here's some issues that you have in your support desk.
I don't have to tell it to do that anymore, guys.
It knows those things.
And so what we're trying to do now is figure out
how we can add it to our zoom messenger
where I have channels with a lot of people there
and it can talk to the whole entire team
and it can keep tabs on any issues or whatever.
I can probably have this thing
where I can add a Twilio phone number
and this thing can call me
and say, Chad, red alert, we got an issue right now.
That's the crazy world that we're living in.
Does everybody get this? Is everybody understanding this,
This so exciting times, right?
So is there anybody interested
in just having articles written for you?
Now you can leave them in a, a draft status, okay?
Um, but you don't have to. It can publish it for you.
Now, uh, as I was saying,
and I know this might go over some people's head,
but we're looking at everything that we have now.
I've never wanted to do this.
And the reason why is I've never wanted to create APIs
to work with other software.
I just didn't care. There wasn't,
there wasn't that great of a demand.
Okay? Now that I've seen
that I can just send an audio file in Telegram
and say, create a pop link, create an article,
create a lead step, create a bridge page.
Now that I can do all that stuff, guys, I don't want it to,
uh, have to log to the browser, right?
Instead, um,
let me see something instead.
Uh, what I wanted to do is I wanted to access all that
behind the scenes through an API, right?
So it's able to like connect behind the scenes,
set everything up for you
and say, boom, here's your pop link.
And if it doesn't have to, so
what do I mean by browser control?
Guys? This thing can actually, I wanna show you guys today,
but I think they're updating, uh,
they're changing the APIs right now.
This thing can actually open up your browser, okay?
So, uh, if you're using a specific piece of software
that you love, you can teach it.
Okay? Open up, go to this URL, go to this link,
click this here, enter this URL, put in the destination,
do this and click save, right?
So you can go put those instructions as a file
and you can put it in there.
And then you can sit here and watch it do its thing
and then say, no, no, no, no, you need
to click that button right there.
It's kind of hidden. And then it'll
do it and say, okay, I got it.
And then you'll tell it. Go ahead and save that as a skill.
And now it saves that skill in its memory bank.
Does that make sense? So it saves all these skills.
It learns about your business, it learns about your hours,
it learns about your teams, and then
it starts setting up a schedule.
And then what you're gonna do, you'll find inside the, uh,
guide guys, once you're all set up and everything,
and I recommend that you join the, the, uh, the shadow call
so you can learn how to do all this stuff.
Uh, once you've set all that up guys, then you're gonna turn
around and say, Hey, what can I be doing better?
Uh, what can I be doing more efficiently?
How can I save more time?
How can I cut down the time on this?
How can I make this convert better? Like what?
It'll not only start suggesting it guys,
but now that it understands what your goals are,
where you're trying to get to like, okay, I want
to get acquired one day.
It will start telling you what to do.
And that's where it's becoming proactive.
Does that make sense to everybody?
Does that make sense? Tom says, I'm broke
and live with a fixed income,
cannot keep buying into your dreams for us.
That's okay. Don't buy into my dreams.
See where that gets you, Tom.
Instead, what I would recommend that you do is go out there
and start working with business owners.
Start going out there and get advertisers.
Start going out there and getting sponsors.
Start actually doing the things that I'm telling you how
to do because people are getting paid.
It's very, very simple, Tom, or else what are options?
We can go out there and try to figure
out, go high level on our own.
We can try to figure these things out on our own. Okay?
But here's my thing. Okay?
I pay over $20,000 a month for all of my developers,
all my staff and everything else.
So if my staff is gonna sit there
and build this thing out for you
and build out your VPS for you and everything else,
and I'm paying my staff, then guess what?
That's the reason why I'm charging you.
And I feel really, really good about that.
Because what is it gonna cost you to try
to figure out all those things on your own?
That's my, that's my theory.
Does anybody else agree with that?
Does any, so what am I gonna do? I'm gonna save you.
Matter of fact, most of you, I can absolutely guarantee
that if you try to do all this on your own, you will fail.
You will fail because you're gonna be up against commands.
You're gonna be up against restarts.
You're gonna be up against four stops.
You're gonna be up against all this stuff.
And you need to, if you're in a position, you need
to invest the time where you're seeing our team deal
with the challenges you're seeing our team deal
with the pitfalls you're seeing our team deal
with how we train things.
You're seeing it in real time.
And then you have the environment
where you can start training it how you want on your own.
Does that make sense? So if it's just a dream for you, Tom,
I'm sorry, because for everybody else here on the call, it's
so much more than just a dream.
Does that make sense? Is there
anybody type in the chat here.
Are you dreaming? Are you gonna make this your reality?
Are you gonna get gobbled up here in a couple years
with your local publication?
Which is it? Which is it guys?
Is it a dream or is this reality for you?
Because I'm gonna tell you right now,
I wanna be freaking showing up two times a week.
If this was a dream for me, hell no. This is not a dream.
We're a board of train.
We're a bill aboard the best technology right now.
I won't even tell you the thousands of dollars
that we've already spent to get things
where we're at right now
with this whole entire new technology and everything, right?
So for the fact that you're able to go
and spend $30 a day to spend two hours with my team
that I'm paying every single month,
and we're gonna go do all that stuff for you.
And you get to be a fly on the wall and you come over here
and do your own thing and then turn around
and say, Hey Chad, I got an idea
for it to do this with my email.
I got an idea for it to do this. What do you think?
Can you help me with the command? Come on y'all.
That's priceless. And you know what?
I wish there was somebody like me growing up when I was
coming up in this business.
I wish somebody was taking me by the hand.
I wish somebody was investing their time,
which is the most valuable thing I have.
The most valuable thing I have at 50 years
old guys is my time.
I'm gonna be here forever.
You guys aren't gonna be here forever.
So let's make the best use of our time.
And right now, this technology is absolutely the
best use of our time.
Okay? Does that make sense?
Now, I also want to point this out, okay?
And if it's not for you, Tom,
you should just leave the call right now.
'cause I don't like apples as fall of the whole damn bunch.
I don't like trains that get started.
Look, if you wanna succeed, you jump aboard with
what I'm telling you, period.
Now I can teach you how to go out there
and set up sales pages and funnels and all that stuff.
And I've done it and I've taught you how to go out there
and set up systems and process
methods, strategy, secret formula.
I've done it. I've done all those things.
The very best chance you have right now with the world
as fast it's moving is to focus on your media company,
focus on you being a publisher.
Does that make sense? And now I'm removing the obstacles.
I'm, I'm removing the fact
that you didn't have time to create the articles.
You didn't have time to create the newsletter.
We're trying to do that with AI automation, okay?
And for me, it's not a dream, right?
It's not a dream at all. Alright? So here's the thing, okay?
Um, and, and, and, and, and that's it.
Like, if, if you don't believe in, in, you know what it is?
I teach and I guys, I I invest. We discover the opportunity.
We crack the code, we invest the money
so that we come to you.
We've already figured out the pitfalls.
We've already figured out the landmine,
and we just say, here, here's a guide.
Do these things, right?
So instead of sitting here saying,
I'm not aboard your dream, or I'm not gonna follow your
dream anymore, when I just gave you a guide
that I personally created this weekend, be grateful.
That's the reason why you're not succeeding.
Does that make sense? That's the reason why.
And you'll never succeed ever, ever, ever.
If anybody's ever, like, I'm chasing dreams with you.
But dude, I'm sorry, that's up here.
We call that a head monster. I'm too young. I'm too old.
It didn't work before. It ain't gonna work this time.
I'm trying to come on now.
You, you, you should go get a job is what you should do.
That's what you should do, right?
And you guys know that I'm tough.
You know that I'm tough love.
But you also know that I will hold you by the hand,
show you how to do something.
And I get a lot of people at the finish line,
and there's no doubt in my mind
that we can't do that, right?
So here's the thing, right? Let's get past, yeah.
Self-limiting beliefs. Get behind them.
Go invest in yourself.
Go invest in personal development or something, man.
Start telling yourself something different.
Start saying to yourself, my God, I am so grateful.
I am so happy that he said that.
I have not missed the AI train.
I'm, I'm so grateful to be on this call
to be at the infant stages.
I'm so grateful for this mentor to go and,
and crack the code and his team that he pays and,
and they're figuring all this stuff out for me.
I'm so grateful to be a part of this community.
I'm so grateful for what's gonna come.
I know that I haven't been able to create bridge pages
and lead steps and write the emails
and everything that he's been talking about.
But not only can I just go and talk
and tell it to do it now, but this thing's gonna tell me
when we should be doing it.
And I'm so very grateful for that.
I'm so very happy for that.
That's when everything starts to change for you, man.
That's when it starts to change.
You gotta start putting something different out there.
You gotta start saying different things.
You gotta start expecting different things.
You gotta start commanding something different of God,
the universe, whatever it is you want, right?
That tree out there. It doesn't want water.
It doesn't needs, it doesn't want sun.
It doesn't want the dirt.
It needs the dirt, the water, the sun. Command it, man.
Command these things of your life. Don't just sit there.
And I've talked about this a lot.
Wherever the waves take me, wherever the waves take me.
No man. Be in control. You call the shots.
Is there anybody calling the shots on this call?
Type in the chat. Let me know.
How many of you are calling the shots for your life?
How many of you're like, you know what? Screw it.
I'm sick of this. I'm sick
of watching everybody else succeed.
I'm getting bought out in two years, period.
I'm gonna have 20,000 subscribers.
I'm gonna be ranked all over Google.
I'm gonna have this AI rocking and rolling.
I'm gonna be teaching businesses how to do this.
'cause 15 to 20% of my people are business owners.
I'm gonna do these meetups.
I'm gonna do everything that Chad's telling me.
I'm gonna automate this ai. You take control.
You take control, period. You accept nothing else.
So everybody says to me, Chad, you're not human.
How do you create an offer in a day?
How do you recognize these opportunities?
How do you shoot these videos so fast?
How do you do a course in a day? How do you do these guys?
How you are not human b******t.
I'm about as human as it gets.
I'm about as human as it gets folks.
I get frustrated, I get p****d, I get lost, I get confused.
I forget. But I ain't gonna fail, period.
I said to myself, this guy's gotta be done.
I got 150 people commenting on my wall.
I'm gonna get this done. Boom, boom, boom, boom.
I got no choice. Solid man. Solid. That's it. I crush.
Anything comes my way. And you
should learn to do those things.
And it starts with what you're telling yourself, man.
It starts with what you're telling yourself.
So tell yourself something different.
Can we all agree to do that?
I used to tell everybody, man, I used to.
I, man, I gotta get back to this.
I used to tell everybody, wake up.
And instead of checking email, instead of checking Facebook
or whatever else, hop on YouTube,
type in motivational videos and sit there
and listen to that stuff for five
or 10 minutes, man,
you will hear the very best in motivation,
the very best in motivation so that you're fired up.
Now here's the difference, guys.
You are not the one doing the work. What do you gotta do?
You gotta recognize the opportunities out there.
You gotta recognize what your goals are in your business.
And now that damn thing does all the work for you. Come on.
Now, you don't have to learn how to build pages and stuff.
You don't have to learn how to write emails.
You just gotta know when the email needs to send.
You just gotta know how to go find the prospects.
You just gotta know how to get the subscribers.
You just gotta know how many
articles to send out every week.
You don't do the work anymore. Does that make sense?
So everything that I have taught for the last, huh,
15 years is now obsolete.
I have taught you guys how to create headlines, how
to create copy, how to create pages, how to, how
to do high ticket programs, how to,
all this stuff I've taught you, it's obsolete.
Now it's just a matter of you recognizing that you need
to control the AI that's gonna be building all that for you.
So I want everybody time in the chat.
Your new goal is to control the ai. Does everybody get this?
We're not using AI anymore. We're controlling the ai.
Up to this point, we've been reactive
and we have been using the ai.
We're no longer gonna use the ai.
Now we're gonna control the ai.
Now you are up here
and you have an assistant down here that is controlling all
of your AI and all the processes
and everything that you have had
to manually do in your business.
And everything that I've been doing, guys, guess what?
You can do this. You can do this too.
It was very, very easy. What did I do?
I recognized an opportunity. It was hot. So what did I do?
I opened up click designs. I made a cover real quick.
You guys can do that. I posted on my wall.
I actually started using the technology.
I actually started cracking the code to it myself,
and I started posting screenshots on the wall.
Oh my God, this is crazy. Look
what this thing's doing, da da, da da.
So what happened? People wanna know, wow,
he cracked the code to some guys.
I have done this over and over and over and over,
and it's not because I'm not human.
It's because I recognize when there's an opportunity
and I strike, I strike when it's hot
and I keep following the same exact process, right?
I recognize the opportunity. I crack the code.
I let everybody know that I've cracked the code.
Then I create some kind of guide, some kind
of free trainer, whatever else.
And I bring people in my world
and every single one of you can do this.
Every single one of you can do this.
No, it's because you have a team bowl.
Did my team work this weekend? G? Did you work this weekend?
Pne? Did you work this weekend?
I'm gonna tell you right now, I'll let them
answer G and pne.
I want you guys to answer that. Nobody worked this weekend.
You know who worked this weekend?
This guy, this guy worked this weekend.
Now did I have a team? Yeah, it was called Pacino.
It was called Pacino.
I talked to Pacino and I said, you know what?
I think this is a hot opportunity.
I think that I'm able to go out there
and get attention on my wall right now.
So I want to learn enough. I wanna crack the code.
Can you work with me? Sure. Where do we start?
Well, first I wanna know about your business. Okay, cool.
So I went into chat GBT, and I said, do me a favor.
I'm trying to type up an introduction for open clock.
Can you do that for me based on what you know?
And it went, so I copied that from Chachi PT
and I plugged it into Open Claw.
I said, perfect. It says I'm gonna save it. My member bank.
Awesome. Then it said, okay,
why don't you tell me about your goals?
I said, well, you know what? We own a software company.
And what I do is I get on calls
and I teach people how to use the software.
Great. Let me plug that into my memory bank.
Then it says, why don't you tell me about your software?
Well, we have member, well we have pop links.
Well, we have Quis forma. Well, we have gc.
And then it understood what I had it said,
tell me what else I said.
Well, I do a call every single Monday.
I do a call every single Friday. Right guys?
I did this on my own all weekend.
And once I cracked the code,
then I said, okay, you know what?
I'm gonna open up PowerPoint
and I'm gonna go create a guide.
And then all of a sudden it occurred to me,
and I showed my mastermind this.
I said, you know what, instead of me doing the work,
I'm gonna ask Fino.
I'm gonna say, Hey, what do you recommend
to create a simple PowerPoint guide today?
Or a simple PDF guide?
It said, well, you know, you can use Gamma
or you can use uh, Canva.
Or I said, you know what? I like to use PowerPoint.
And the reason why is because I'm able to go and update it
and people can get the updates.
I said, can you do anything with that?
I said, sure, I can create a PowerPoint.
I said, why don't you give it a shot? Boom.
It created the PowerPoint.
Except it wasn't horizontal
or it wasn't vertical, it was horizontal.
So I came back and said, no, it needs to be vertical, right?
So it went back and it created a vertical.
And then I said, well, here's my cover
that I created with click designs.
Can you make it more beautiful?
It said, oh, I love that branding.
And it went and it redid the branding.
So then I sat there and opened up PowerPoint
and I said, okay, I wanna make sure
that everybody can actually understand all this.
So I worked with GPT, right?
And I kept sending it pictures of each PowerPoint slide
and I created the guide myself.
Then I took out my phone
and I created a very, very personal video telling everybody
about why this is the most important AI technology.
Then I went and I created a simple, uh, page inside
of our software and boom, I went
and answered everybody on the wall
and I did it all myself, Tom.
I did it all myself. Are you there G pne?
You guys there right now?
Yeah, I'm here. Did you work this weekend, G?
No, I reached out to you.
But you were gone, weren't you? Yeah. Yeah.
I reached out to him. I wanted to make sure he was okay
with us doing his shadow program, but he didn't answer.
I talked to pne once this weekend.
Gee, to your knowledge, did anybody work this weekend?
I don't think so. No.
It was just me, right? I give you guys the weekend.
Yeah. And when you showed up, what did you see today?
Yeah, you had all the guys ready, you had the plan
for the setup program, all of that.
You even had the pace, uh, the open cloud one.
Yeah. I'm not a developer, am I?
No, I don't know anything about that stuff, do I?
Nope. But guys, I'm very determined.
Does that make sense? So don't sit here and tell me it's
because I have a team.
Does that make sense? I wanna make sure everybody gets this.
Is everybody crystal clear now?
Oh, and by the way, Connie was sick in bed.
She hasn't come outta bed for three days. She's really sick.
The kids are all sick here. Okay?
So I was on my own yesterday. I said, okay, you know what?
I'm gonna stay on this end of the house
'cause I can't afford to get sick right now.
You guys are too dependent on me, right?
So you'll learn to do all this stuff if you really wanna
learn how, join the mastermind.
This is what we're focused on,
but now we're gonna focus on the AI stuff as well, right?
So look, man, I don't put up with BS excuses at all.
I don't. 'cause you wanna know why the minute I put up
with BX excuses
and people think it's okay for them
to fail in this business, oh, it's not your fault.
The technology's too complicated.
The strategies are too advanced. No bs bs.
Every single one of you have the ability
to post something on your wall that's free traffic.
Every single one of you have the ability to open up chat GPT
and say, can you make a logo
for the open cloth shadow intensive?
Boom. There it was. Then I said, you know what?
I need to put some sales copy on it. 'cause I'm tired.
I'm freaking tired. I learned a two new technology.
I cracked the code to it. I wrote an ebook.
I created the page, I created the video.
I sent out two emails. I'm tired.
Can you create the copy for this page? Boom, there it was.
I plugged into membered and I was done. Make sense?
Every single one of you can do this.
Now, how many of you're thinking, you know what?
I got some skills I need to learn. I got some skills.
So look, so you wanna be a slave to media
and not really be living?
Who says, I'm not living man, I gotta serve people.
Tom, do you understand? I gotta serve people.
All you gotta do is recognize an opportunity
and not be negative with it.
Make sense? But I got a lot of people I could serve.
How many of you think the work that I did yesterday
and I avoided getting sick at the same time?
How many of you think the work
that I did is gonna make a huge transformational
value in so many lives?
How many of you believe that to be true? Anybody?
Does anybody believe that
that work can provide a transformational value?
Of course it is, man. It's going to change lives.
We're at the infant stages of something amazing
and I'm actually taking action.
I'm not just out there posting about it
and all the drama, and here's what it does.
No, man. You see me using it
and you're gonna see my team using it.
Yeah. So that's my story though, Tom,
that don't have to be your story.
Nobody needs to do a weekly call if they don't want to.
Nobody needs to do a Friday call if they don't want to.
Nobody needs to build software if they don't want to.
There's a lot of headaches with that, right?
But I'm gonna tell you right now,
you ought to be building a newsletter.
And I gave you the damn newsletter.
I gave it to you for your, for my birthday.
I gave it to you. I gave you a $297 gift.
I spent all day and I created a guide. I gave that to you.
Come on guys. I don't know.
I, I don't, I don't know how to pave the way
any clearer than what I'm doing.
Do you guys absolutely do not know how to do that? Right?
So I'm, I'm, I'm rooting for everybody.
But watch what you say to yourself.
Please watch what you say to yourself.
It's really, really important.
And, and, and, and, and,
and by the way, it's really, really easy to start going down
that rabbit hole just like it is to take off.
It's really easy, right?
You start saying something negative,
then you start saying something negative.
Then you try to justify why,
and you try to prove that that negative thing is true.
And, and then, then, and that's how you fail.
Man, I, I told my team this morning, I said,
from this point forward, here's how we do things.
And we go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
And there's a freaking win every single day.
It's win every single day. It's win every single day.
It's win every single day.
And for some reason, if we trip, I am trained
to get us back to that win.
I'm trained to pivot really, really fast.
'cause I recognize how important wins are.
Does that make sense? Gotta get the win. Gotta get the win.
For some of you's creating articles, for some
of you's pumping out newsletters for some
of you's bringing in a hundred subscribers a week.
Whatever it is, whatever your win is, you gotta get it.
You gotta recognize it, you gotta pat it,
you gotta pat yourself on the back when you get that win.
Yeah, we good?
So we recognize that we gotta create some APIs.
We're pretty excited about doing that. Okay.
Um, but here's the other thing too, right?
And I'm, I'm, I'm gonna come back
and ask you guys, uh, you know, where you see a use
for API in our business?
Because I, I want that thing.
Oh man, I want
that thing cranking out our technology.
We built our technology where it's so easy,
but now I can just talk to it and have it do it.
Is there anybody that's like, how many of you believe
that this is gonna set you free?
Type in the chat. Let me know who believes
that this is gonna set you free.
You've known, I've shown you,
I've shown you what you need to do.
You need to create an article.
You need to create at least four every single week.
You need to create one for your dog.
You need to create one for your food.
And then you pull 'em into your news.
I've, I've been telling you these things, man.
I've been telling you. Put a button on the page.
I've been telling you, create your own system, process,
method, strategy, secret form.
I've been telling you those things.
I've been showing you those things.
I've been pulling back the curtain and showing you
how easy I've put together these things.
But yet not everybody's able to do it.
Well now, now you are.
Now you are because you're not gonna do the work yourself
anymore, right?
So we wanna create those APIs where it can do it really,
really fast and it can do it in a very,
very cost effective manner.
Does that make sense? And guys, I'm telling you right now,
I knew the day was coming.
I knew the day was coming. It's here. It's here.
I'm super excited, right?
So if you're a naysayer, if you don't believe in this man,
I don't know what, say you don't wanna be on this call.
'cause my people will beat you up.
'cause they're not gonna let any bad apples spoil the bunch
because we're on a, we're on track.
We're off to the races.
We've gone through a lot of obstacles, a lot
of challenges here in this business, in this life.
Partners, everything else. Uhuh, we're off.
We're going, is there anybody wants to go with me?
It's go, go, go, go, go From this point forward.
Yeah, it's go, go go.
I told my team it's go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
That's it. Everything changes today.
The way we build software changes the way
that we're implementing AI changes.
The way that we're putting ourselves out there.
Changes the speed in which we're doing things, changes,
everything changes from this point forward.
Yeah, it's time to pivot folks. Time to pivot.
I believe in it, but I need a structure. Guess what?
Let that thing learn about your business.
Let it train on the skills you need.
It will create the structure for you.
That's what I'm trying to tell you.
It will, it will tell you
how you should be running your business.
That's what we've been seeing.
And guys, some of you need that. I need that.
I simply said, Hey, can you tell me things now
that you understand my business,
can you tell me some things that I can do better?
Right? Let me share with you some things on my wall.
Then we're gonna take a look at the new newsletters
that launch, and then how are we doing
with the keyword thing, uh, G
Okay, let me send you, Perfect.
So, uh, just to kind of show you, I wanted to do a demo,
but I'm not gonna be able to do a demo
today, but that's okay.
Um, they woke up doing, um,
Ted, on your dm, there's a link.
If you open that, it would open up a later man.
And then I think you can demo over there. It's a dev one.
Okay, perfect. Well, we'll do a demo on that.
I'm just not gonna be able to demo, uh, open claw, right?
Yeah. Okay. Can you guys see my screen time?
How many of you can see my screen right now?
This is what I posted on my wall. This is my telegram.
Does everybody, let me, let me find the chat.
This is my telegram guys, look at this. Look at this.
Perfect articles. All said, here's what I completed.
The Arizona and Colorado fortify legal reserves, uh,
status published, SEO keywords,
Colorado River water rights litigation, add to archive,
check newsletter, queue Disabled, no index,
left unchecked word count 558 words featured image,
west Valley Shadows logo automatically added.
The articles now live and available in the archives.
So let's go look at that, guys. Check this out.
Look at this. Look how crazy.
This is not the XML,
but let's look at the, uh, let me look at the archives.
Archives. Look at this. Look how insane this is. Guys.
That thing went and created this guy right here.
Do you guys see this? It created this article.
I did nothing to this. Are you guys seeing this right now?
I did nothing to it.
It automatically went and created the whole entire thing.
And then I don't know if I, I loaded that
'cause I was trying to show the people on Facebook.
I'll show you some of these other things.
Um, I, I said, Hey, you can't use the logo here.
Uh, can you find an image?
It says, do you want me to create an image? I'm like, sure.
So it went and created this image. Like it, it did.
And guys we're just at the start.
So this is what I'm talking about.
We're gonna build an API
that does all this for you right now.
It logged into Letterman, it went to your publication,
it clicked on ADD article, it pasted it.
No, we're not gonna do it that way.
Okay, we're gonna do it with an API.
We're already working on it, right? Uh, let's see.
I wonder if it created the article.
It takes about a minute for it generate. Good point.
Let me check if it actually created the article.
Despite long wait, let me look at the articles.
Yes, it worked. The article was successfully created.
I can now see it open in the editor. Look at this guys.
And not only that, it learns. It learns from its mistake.
It learns from its mistake, right?
Chad, I have successfully demonstrated the workflow.
Look at this one. I logged into Vimeo.
I found the Zoom recordings.
I located the local newsletter hour video call.
I extracted the URLI logged into pop links.
I found 26 newsletter, the last replay.
I cloned the bridge page. What's left after I need this?
Wait for pop links to finish cloning.
Find the new clone page, edit it, change the title from 26
to 27, update the video, video URL to here
and change the slug from 26 to 27.
Publish bottom line. I can automate this entire flow.
When the real Monday call happens,
just tell me the call topic for the headline and I'll do it.
Are you guys seeing this?
Are you guys seeing this right now?
Lemme get back to where I was. Hold on a second.
Look at this man. I was going nuts.
I was going nuts all weekend, right? So, uh, perfect.
I got pop link gxi, I logged into pop links.
I found the latest. Okay, this is
what I just showed you, right?
Let me see what else it did.
Um, I'm now on the page brow builder.
Look at page brow with the clone copy,
the local newsletter hour.
I could see that there's a countdown at the top.
The big headline about the Hustle 2.0 course.
The video embed full page builder on the right
with background color layout controls.
This is their drag and drop builder.
I can edit the text and headline, change the color
and background, swap out the video,
modify the countdown timer and remove sections.
Do you want me to customize this clone page in one
completely from scratch to show you the full guys?
It learns, it freaking learns.
It opened up our software
and it said, oh, I know what's going on here
and here's what I could do.
It learned faster than you
and me combined it learned, right?
I just created a pop link for you.
I called it the eBay link. Here's the tracking.
URL, here's the destination. It's active created just now.
You can see it in the Link Bank. First row on the table.
The link is live and ready to track link.
Come on folks, come on. Boom.
I can see your pop links.
Dashboard navigation shows, dashboard, pop links,
poppage traffic, glass, special
pages, page snippets, all leads.
Universal time. Look it logged in
and it new it knew exactly what to do.
Uh, so tag based automation in your GC system.
When someone gets tagged, it fires off.
Workflows, integrations automatically.
What I can help with is creating the tag.
Send it the tag themselves in gc, build the triggers.
Configure what happens when a tag is applied.
Email workflows, integrations. Automate the tag assignment.
Apply tags based on behavior conditions to make this work.
Does GC have an API for tags or workflows?
Oh, it's going to, it is going to.
What kind of integrations get triggered? Email.
Zapier internal workflows.
Are these one-off setups or something you need to scale?
Repeat example, flow em.
Imaging the tag completed the course module trigger sends
configuration, email update, progress,
unlock Module two, notify in Slack.
Is that the kind of automation you're thinking?
And this ties into course brow completion tracking.
What is there anybody blown away on
what you're seeing here right now?
This is Telegram.
While I'm laying in bed, I was doing this in bed.
This is what I was doing in bed guys. Uh, look at this one.
I asked it, do you think you can create a course?
And I gave it access to Course Sprout. It said Perfect.
To make this work, I need to know, does does it have an API
or do I automate through the browser?
Oh, it's going to have an API Vimeo integration.
How do videos get pulled from Vimeo
and course Brow API connection?
We went and added the API.
Now it pulls it through the API goal blocks.
What's the structure format?
Is it a specific template or freeform lesson format?
What sections do lessons typically have? Intro content.
Example summary, the dream workflow.
You record, upload it to a Vimeo folder.
I watch, I transcribe each video,
I write the lesson description based on the content.
I load the videos into course brow.
I create matching goal blocks. Done.
If Course Brow has an API, this becomes fully automatable.
If not browser automation works too.
I saved it when I saw create the pop link,
when I saw create the article, I said, man,
I need something to do.
I need something to show people during the shadow calls.
We're gonna do all this stuff, guys. All of it, everything.
Look at this when it created the image, perfect.
We're signed in. Now let me enter the Colorado River
prompt and generate the image.
Great. The image is generated.
We're generating the image for you.
Let me wait for it's finished. Stunning images generated all
four look amazing with the Colorado River.
We're winding through Red Rock Funions.
Let me download the best one and upload it to your article.
Perfect. Now let me download it. Perfect image downloading.
Let me navigate to your Letterman article and upload it.
Excellent. I can see the article editor
with a set photo button.
Let me click it to upload the AI generated Colorado image.
Perfect. The image uploaded dialogue open.
I can see add image toggles on.
Let me click the image upload icon.
It's like the download Colorado River Image. Perfect.
The file picker should have come on now. It's learning.
I'm not even teaching it. It's learning itself.
Do you guys understand this right now? Time to chat.
Let me know if you're getting this.
It's amazing. Do you guys understand why?
So we're gonna train it on those skills.
You're not gonna spend thousands of dollars Tom training it.
I'm gonna spend the money for you
and we're gonna go train it.
We're gonna do it for the next two weeks.
We're gonna spend a lot of money training it,
saying there's gonna be a lot of trial
and error in how we train things and everything else, right?
But we're gonna train it. We're gonna train it on Letterman.
We're gonna train it on page brow.
We're gonna train it on pop lanes.
We're gonna, we're gonna train it on as many things
as we possibly can so that we can just give you a plugin
and you can just go and unload that plugin.
And your bot is trained where you don't have
to spend the money training it.
Does that make sense? Does everybody get this right now?
So I'm gonna take the hit.
I'm gonna go learn all this stuff for you.
But at the same time, if you don't think I'm not out there
on my wall sharing everything we're doing,
and if you don't think I'm not gonna go out there
and pop out videos on one
of the hottest technologies right now, guess again,
because I gotta show my mastermind how
to recognize an opportunity
and capitalize on it as fast as we possibly can.
Does that make sense? Kristen says,
your services are the most
professional I've ever experienced.
Good, good, good. Let me look at this demo.
Uh, we're not done with this yet.
We're, uh, but I wanna see if I can show this to you.
It might be done by today. Okay?
So, um, g what's the login for this?
Uh, you can just log into your account.
Perfect. To Connie's or mine?
Any you want where you wanna create the article? Okay,
IM gonna log in here guys.
And then, uh, oops, I spelled this wrong.
Alright, so
lemme share my screen again.
I might need G's help with this.
I'm showing you something that's in development right now.
It's been a little tricky, but
it's gonna be really, really good.
So am I. Okay, let me share my screen again. Check this out.
Share a screen one. All right.
Does everybody see this right now? Do you see my screen G?
Yeah, I see it. So I'm gonna come over here.
I'm gonna add article. Okay?
And what I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna come over here
and I'm just gonna look for, uh, open claw real quick
and let me look at the news.
Uh, yeah,
let's try these guys right here.
It's a little bit harder 'cause I can tell we're probably
not gonna be able to scrape a lot of these.
Let me see if we can scrape like this one.
Probably not MSN, right? A lot of these we can't scrape.
This is why I like local guys
because we don't have to worry about it with local.
But let me see if I can scrape this one. Nope.
See, I can't scrape it. See how it turns red?
I can't scrape it. Well, guess what?
Your open claw, your Pacino also knows,
uh, it can check and make sure
that it can be scraped, right?
So, uh,
let me just try something else.
It's really, really hard.
The niche stuff is really, really hard guys.
This is why I love the, this is what I'm gonna do.
I'm just gonna pretend like this is the Summerland one.
You're saying I could have done this in Summerland.
Uh, I could do, I could do this in her account, G
'cause I'm confused on what you gave me.
Um, okay,
Can I do this in her account or no?
Yeah, you can do it on your account.
Okay. So let me come over here
and I'm gonna show you guys and then we're gonna find a way
to make this work with the bot, okay?
Um, but if I come over here and I click on my publications
and my internet is really, really slow right now,
and I'm gonna click on add article,
just like you guys always have, okay?
And so now Open Claw is gonna come over here
and it's always gonna find the stories for you, okay?
So I'm just gonna type in Summerlin, Nevada, okay?
And I'm gonna click on news.
And so now this is what Open Claw is gonna do, right?
So we got this, uh, teen accused of recording.
Uh, actually don't want that one. Popular Wine Comfort.
Okay, let's go with this one.
So I'm gonna go ahead and grab this article here
and I'm gonna come back over here.
I'm gonna plug it in and uh, I'm just gonna go ahead
and grab, oh, this is right around the corner.
We've been wanting to eat here.
Does anybody, has anybody ever eaten at a Zippy's
five Save?
Yeah, it's literally right around the corner.
I just took pictures of it the other day
so I could just go load my own pictures actually.
Um, but let me
see if I can get that's loading.
Hold on a second. Let me see if I can show you
camera CAM.
So it just so happens that
we were driving by the other day for their ground opening,
and this will give you guys some good advice.
Uh, and I started snapping pictures
of Zippy's, right?
Lemme find a good one. See, that's BJ's. Hold on.
I'm always snapping pictures. This is a good one.
So let me see if I can share this. Share.
Ah, there we go. I can share it in Zoom.
Okay, look at this picture. Share nicely share.
Okay, so here's the one that I grabbed,
which belongs to somebody else.
But if you, if you're, this is
what I love about the local stuff, guys,
if you're already in the area, right?
Let me see if I can grab this guy
and I'll open this up and I'll show you.
I just sent it to myself in Zoom.
So here's the picture I took the other
day, Dave.
All right, so let's try this again.
So I'm gonna go ahead and grab this link
with their popup and everything.
And I'm gonna say add article.
And we're gonna go ahead and put, put that there.
Let's make sure we can scrape it.
Even if we can't scrape it, uh, we can come over here
and do it manually, but it's green so we can scrape it.
And um, I'm having an indexing
problem on this drive.
But you'll see the article that,
or you'll see the picture that I created,
at least I think you will.
Yeah, here we go. Uh, so here's, here's the picture I took.
Here's the official picture. We're stealing, right?
So I'm gonna go ahead and load the one I took. Okay?
So here it is, right here. And then I'm just gonna go ahead
and grab, uh, this headline as long
as it has the word summerlin,
but we're gonna help you understand that.
Okay? So I'm gonna go ahead and put that in there
and see how it says keyword summary at the top.
So I'm gonna use Chachi,
bt I'm gonna go ahead and go to the next step.
All right? Now this isn't live yet guys, but it's coming.
Okay? This is coming.
If you have Josh's tool, this is coming.
So what Letterman's doing right now is it's gonna go
and it's gonna find keywords
that it thinks you can rank for.
And then what we're doing is we're sending it back over
to Josh's tool and then it's giving you the search volume.
Is everybody seeing this right now?
That's pretty crazy, right?
So we're not done with this yet,
but no matter what, it's gonna put Summerlin in there.
So now I have Hawaiian Comfort Foods, Zippy's, Las Vegas
and Summerlin restaurants.
Those are the three that I want to rank for.
And by the way, remember we're gonna train open claw
to handle all this for you.
Does that make sense? So this is the search volume,
this is the difficulty, and then this is the trend.
And then this is the cost per click.
So everything that you can do in his software we're now
doing inside of our software.
So if you bought Josh's platform, you guys can see
that we are integrating it, right?
So what's gonna happen, and this is where we're working,
we're working on the SEO summary today.
When I go to the next step, it's gonna give you a preview
and we gotta make this screen look better.
So just kind of bear with me right now,
it's gonna give you a preview of
what the headline should be, uh,
and uh, what the, uh, H two headline should be,
the primary keywords and the secondary keywords.
And this way, does everybody understand this way
you are going to start ranking for these keywords.
Does that make sense? Time in the chat.
Lemme know if you get this. So the first goal is we're gonna
get you indexed with this URL on these keywords.
The second goal is you're gonna start ranking
for these keywords, especially when you
start applying his link juice.
And that's the next thing I wanna talk to you about. Okay?
So what's gonna happen is now we're gonna come over here
and we're gonna create article.
And this is the part we're still working
on right now, right G
Yeah, that's what we are working on.
This is what we're working on. So we're almost there.
We're almost there guys.
So everything that I promise you that we are gonna do
with his tool, we are absolutely doing.
Now let me tell you something else too.
This is a big update. Uh, I gotta meet with a team.
I I gotta go to the hospital first
and then I gotta meet with a team on this.
Uh, but if I were
to type in West Valley shoutouts.com/articles xml,
this is the file.
No, you don't wanna wait, right? The person 1130, okay?
All right, message me. Would you don't forget the crickets?
Okay, um, hold on a second.
Uh, this is a file
articles do XML that you're gonna put inside
of the DFY suite.
Now here's the catch.
Like I said, I'm gonna work at the team,
I'm gonna fix this for you today.
We had Chris Tolin that went and loaded his file
and he didn't see any activity on his link.
So I've been going back and forth with him and Josh and
and Josh's team and I'm like, why aren't we,
he loaded this file.
Why aren't we seeing anything guys?
Your dates have to be after your submissions.
Does that make sense? So all your old articles right now,
if you've taken that URL
and plugged it into Josh's software,
all your old articles are not gonna get linked juice.
So we need to fix that.
I'm gonna fix that with my team where we're gonna go
into your, somehow I gotta figure something out.
So when you submit your, your, your site map in there,
everything that you create after that date, it will grab.
But now what I gotta do is I gotta find a way.
I don't know how we're gonna do it,
but I gotta find a way to go take all your old articles
and I gotta find a way to change the date
where they're gonna get index two.
Does that make sense? Time in the chat.
Lemme know if everybody's getting this.
Okay, so we're working on it. We are working on it, right?
So we have the article XML working, okay?
So if you, if you go into Josh's tool,
you take your article XML, you submit it,
every single article that you create is going to, um,
start getting ranked, okay?
You're gonna start getting linked use,
but this is gonna make sure
that you're using the right keywords.
Does that make sense everybody?
I wanna make sure everybody's getting this.
This will make sure you're using the right keywords.
And this is why I can see it, man.
I don't mean to be hard on Tom,
but I'm like, my God, we worked so hard.
I can see it, I can see you guys dominating freaking Google.
I can see it, I can see West Valley shadows taking the
whole entire three pages, guys, I can see it Now,
I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna let the cat outta the bag,
but I'm gonna tell you right now that we have an 800 pound
gorilla that is watching everything that we're doing
and it's win of Connie's clients.
And she's gotta be very, very careful.
She keeps coming to me saying, what should I say to him?
He asked me this, he asked me that. What should I say?
Because they're trying to figure out what we're doing.
The city, the city is trying to figure out what we're doing.
They're trying to, they're trying
to copy everything they're doing with our newsletter.
They're trying to figure out our articles.
They're trying to, they don't even
know about the link juice.
They don't even, they don't even understand SEO that I,
I told her, I'm like, look, this can go
one of two ways, man.
They've already came after you once.
So here's the thing, we can play nice, we can help them.
And you'll probably take over not only the city,
but all the other cities they own.
'cause they own a ton of cities. I said, that can happen
or we can probably get in a fight here
because you're doing things so well.
You're man, the things that you guys are learning,
not only learning, but just tapping into the freaking SEO
that we're doing for you now, finding the keywords,
writing the articles with intention,
and now on top of that, just
piling high PR backlinks with the schema, with the site map.
Like with all that stuff, guys, look, I can see it,
I can visualize it.
Is there anybody else that is like visualizing that day?
And for some reason, look,
I've been worried ever since my lawsuit,
my partnership fell apart.
My plans for seven years all came to an end.
I was like, my god, what's gonna happen?
What's gonna happen guys?
When we create, when we came out those articles
and when we started understanding
that we're creating a media company,
and then I understood that it doesn't really matter
what happens to ai, it doesn't matter what happens
to affiliate marketing.
When I understood that, when I understood I could get
gobbled up and all I had to do is build a subscriber base
and dominate Google, dude, all the bricks off my shoulder,
they just fell.
Is there anybody else feeling that way?
I had so much security for my retirement, I knew for a fact
that I could go out there and sell out
and start all over again.
And, and like, man, you guys, you learned to craft.
Does that make sense? I believe that you learned to craft,
if you take what we're doing with the publication,
that's the opportunity, okay?
A lot of people, look, a lot
of people are copying me right now.
I can promise you that they're going through the guide.
They're gonna rip me off, they're gonna rip off my video,
they're gonna rip off my shadow.
I already know that people rip me off.
I already know other marketers
that can't figure stuff out for themselves.
They just rip other people off.
They don't crack the code themselves.
I already know I'm gonna get ripped off.
And then they're gonna go out there
and they're gonna do their workshops
and they're gonna do their events
and they're gonna do their hoorah,
but they're not actually doing anything.
But guess what? So what all these people are doing anything,
but guys, guess what they're missing?
They're missing the opportunity.
They don't have the local newsletter.
They don't, they're not teaching people
to put a button on a page.
They're not telling people you need to crack the code
and have your own system, process,
method, strategy, secret formula.
Do you understand that? Does everybody get this?
Does everybody get this time of the chat? Lemme know.
Tom says, been thinking about
this type of life for many years.
Good. Keep thinking that Tom, man, keep thinking that.
Create a vision board for yourself.
Watch YouTube videos every day, man.
Start telling yourself something.
Look, I'm gonna, I'm gonna give you guys a secret right now.
You guys wanna know a secret to success right now?
Do you wanna know something incredible right now?
Do you wanna, I I'm I'm gonna give you two exercises
that I think you guys can do.
Do you guys, do you wanna learn these things?
I put this together myself.
I believe that God gave me this download,
and that's what I believe in.
And I do this as as much as I possibly can.
Do I do it every day? No. Sometimes I'm too tired.
Sometimes I'm too cranky. Sometimes I got too much going on.
Sometimes the phone's ringing at three o'clock in the
morning 'cause some domain is down or something.
SSL. But I'm gonna tell you guys right now,
I'll lay in my bed and in my silently,
silently I will start saying thank you.
I will say, I will start saying thank you, uh,
for, for Katerina.
Thank you for making her, uh, one
of the top lawyers in the state of Wyoming.
Thank you for making her so successful.
Uh, you know, thank you for giving her the gift skills
and abilities to, uh, go out there and,
and change the lives of so many of her clients.
And to bring peace, love, grace, all of that.
Ease, grace, peace, trust, health, wealth, success and love.
Thank you, thank you, thank you. And then I go to Cat
and then I go to Madeline.
Thank you so much for the gift skills
and abilities that you've given her.
Thank you for, uh, allowing her to have the courage
to go out there and open her own bakery business.
Thank you for her photography business.
Thank you, thank you, thank you for
her succeeding in college.
Thank you for her getting to everything she wants in life.
Thank you for her dream home.
Thank you for her dream husband that she has.
And then I go to Connie, thank you so much for her having,
uh, as many clients as she wants to be able
to pick and choose her clients.
Thank you for giving her those high
dollar extension clients.
Thank you for giving her the confidence on camera.
Thank you for giving her the, the confidence
to put herself on the newsletter.
Thank you for giving her the ability to get gobbled up
for millions of dollars where she changes her life.
And then I go to her. Boy Jace, thank you so much
for giving him the courage to hop on here
and start learning, uh, YouTube videos.
And thank you so much for giving him the strength
to open up his phone and start building vibe coding.
And, and thank you so much for giving him the, the,
the strength and the the know-how to go out there
and create its own YouTube
channel and build this whole list.
And, and guys, I sit there and I'll give myself a headache
because I will go through every single person I care about
in my life and I will start forecasting their life.
I do it for my mastermind members too.
I will start forecasting the life that I want for them.
Do you understand this a lot? I do it a lot.
I do it a lot, man. I'm for, so you keep, go ahead.
I guess keep telling yourself whatever you want,
but I'm gonna lay there and I'm gonna
forecast things for you.
And then I do it for myself.
Man, thank you for giving me these downloads.
Thank you for giving me these gifts.
Thank you for giving me this incredible team.
Thank you for giving me this vision.
Thank you for giving me this drive. Thank you.
All these things all the time, man.
Nonstop all the time.
And that's when your life starts to change.
But I'm gonna tell you something right now.
Is there anybody that's ever been burned?
Is there anybody that's ever been burned
by another human being on this call?
Anybody at all? Anybody?
Look, you're not an entrepreneur until you've been sued.
I've been sued two times.
Is there anybody that's been burned?
Is there anybody that has stolen money from them?
Stolen ideas from them?
Lied, cheated, still anybody Has any human
being ever let you down?
'cause I'm gonna tell you guys right now,
I'm gonna tell you another secret.
And this was just somehow passed on to me.
And I don't know, I can sit there and I can visualize.
And for me it's baseball.
I can visualize this person that has burned me so bad
and they're on my team and I'm their coach.
And they step up to the plate.
And when they step up to the plate,
they're not holding that bat, right?
They're not in the right position or whatever.
And as me, as a coach, I'm able to come over
and I'm able to hold their hand.
I'm able to position the bat.
I'm able to tell 'em, okay, go ahead and pull it back.
Go ahead and open up your legs, everything.
And I can see the look on their face.
I can see how bad they feel for the things they did.
And yet, what am I doing?
I'm sitting here trying to help 'em.
You want, you wanna know why? Because I want them to win.
I want them to win. And when that pitch comes out, I'm there
with them and I'm holding it
and I'm saying, you know what, we're gonna knock this over
the park and I swing as hard as I possibly can to get
that person that win.
And that ball goes far, far, far, far, far center field.
And it's over. And there you go.
That person that burned me, they're fricking with whatever.
So the lawsuit stealing the software,
whatever they're doing, I can visualize them.
I can see them running
and as they're running to first base, I can see the tears,
I can see the hurt, I can see the regret.
And as they hit first base, I can see them rounding
to get over here to second base.
And I, and you know what?
Deep down inside, I want them to get the win.
I don't wanna keep playing with them.
I want 'em to get the win.
And as they come around third base or whatever, I can see it
and they're just in freaking tears.
'cause for some of 'em, for the first time ever,
they are absolutely winning.
They knocked it over the park. They had the home run.
And you know what happens is they start coming
to home plate, all of a sudden they just disappear.
They disappear. They hit a home plate, they walk off
and I never see them again.
And you know what? That visual exercise
guys, it frees me.
It frees me up so much.
And I leave going, you know what? I'm a good coach.
I'm a good person. I got a good heart.
I still want the people that burn me to win.
And not only do I want them to win, I want them
to hit a freaking home run.
And it's at that very minute right there
that I realize, you know what?
You have forgiven, you've moved on
and you have no bad intentions out there whatsoever.
Now I can go really, really deep with you
and I believe that our spirits on another level
and that all that is, is being witnessed on a greater scale.
But that frees you, that frees you of, of any hard feelings
or ill intentions or guilt
or anything to where now there's no reason I cannot blame.
And I will not blame. I cannot blame any past partner.
I cannot blame, you know,
I brought my sister in the business that went bad.
I, I've had exes. I cannot blame any of those people.
'cause all I want is for them to win.
I just want them for the win. And that frees me.
And therefore I'm able to go out there and succeed.
I'm free. Those two exercises, guys, you can do
during what's called the rem stage, when you first wake up,
you can do that in the morning and you can go out there
and take the people that you care about
and elevate them higher than anything they have.
And at the same time, you can rid of the hurt
and uh, everybody that, that did damage in your life
and has, has been your excuse
and your crutch and everything else.
Those two exercises God gave me,
I didn't learn it from anywhere.
I didn't, it was something that I cracked the code to.
Uh, and I've always done it.
And I cracked the code to that about three years ago.
I don't think I've ever shared that with anybody, uh,
except my friend Alan.
He said that was a download from
God, something that you needed.
And I don't know, maybe, maybe it can help you.
Maybe it can help you too.
Uh, is there anybody, does that help?
Does that help you guys? Is that something you can do?
Is that something you can do?
Because, uh, James says, needed this today.
Maybe, maybe you do need this. I don't know.
I don't know where this stuff comes from.
I'm just trying to tell you guys
that there are real head monsters up here.
And look man, there's gonna be some people.
We're gonna, we're gonna hop on this shadow call
and we're gonna set up their VPS for them
and we're going to install cloud bond on Friday.
We're gonna do all those things.
And yet there's gonna be some people that are scared
to type a message that you know, why?
'cause of what's up here. They still are telling themself,
even now you got an army
that's gonna go build out whatever you want every single
day, give you a report, tell you
what you should be doing different.
And there's still gonna be people,
it's even gonna recognize opportunities for you.
And there's still gonna be people that are like,
oh, I can't do this.
Oh, I don't deserve success. Oh, I'm too old.
Oh, I'm too young. Oh, I don't have enough time.
Oh, I don't understand. Oh, it's complicated.
They're still there. They're still there.
And, and that stuff that, that's gotta get fixed, folks.
It's gotta get fixed, man. It's gotta get fixed.
Does that make sense? Tom says, brother, you're
what we call being a human being far and few.
I just have good intentions, Tom.
I went through a divorce
and uh, I heard a song from, uh, my client, uh,
called Be Still and Know I'm God.
And I learned a verse, Psalms 46 10,
and that's what it says, be still and know I'm God.
And I went out there and I posted that on my wall
and I really said, okay, you know what?
I'm just gonna chill out.
My daughter came back to me,
my business got back on track when I realized that,
you know, I'm not in control of everything.
And then I had a guy that scammed me for about $35,000 in a,
uh, uh, a day trading scam.
But before I paid him $35,000, I got on a call.
'cause it was the most money I'd ever
seen on the phone before.
And I said, how, how do you create an offer for $35,000?
And he told me something that changed my life forever.
And I posted on my wall and I stuck with it ever since.
And he said, Chad, what you have
to do is provide a transformational value
in the lives of other people.
And it clicked. I said, okay, so for $35,000, I just have
to provide a transformational value.
What I learned was my time. Okay?
Uh, and then he ripped me off.
He didn't deliver 35,000, whatever,
probably the best $35,000 I've ever paid for.
Seriously? I went and bought laptops and everything
and I learned about the candle tips and everything,
and I, I really wanted to do it.
He didn't show up for the second session,
took everybody's money and ran,
but probably the best $35,000 I ever spent
because I learned that my goal was
to provide a transformational value in the lives of
so many people with ease, grace, peace, trust, health,
wealth, success and love for everybody.
Do you understand? That's my mission every single day.
So tough love. Yeah, I'm tough.
I'm tough because I saw my father die at 50 years old,
or I'm sorry, 65 years old.
And I realize right then and there, life is short.
Life is very short. If I follow my footsteps,
my father's footsteps, I got 15 years left.
Life is short. So no, every single day I'm gonna show up.
I started feeling sniffly and headache and everything else.
And Uhuh, I refuse.
So I got up outta bed,
I took a shower, I got on with the guides.
I, uh, uhuh. No, no, no, no. I'm not getting sick.
I am not getting sick. I'm in control.
That ain't gonna happen, period. That's it.
So everybody else keeps asking me, they're like, Chad,
how come you're the only one not sick?
Because I gotta freaking, I'm,
I gotta drive like I gotta provide for so many people.
I gotta provide a transracial
value for the lives of so many people.
I can't do that when I'm sick.
That's not an option right now. Make sense?
That's that, that's that drive, man.
And uh, I I I just need you to be big and bold
and not worry about what people think.
Put yourself out there. Put yourself out on the wall.
Take a chance. Recognize these opportunities.
You got one life, man. Make it happen. Make it happen.
Mind over matter. Yeah, of course. Just go crush it.
Don't worry about what people think.
Don't worry about pe People say, don't worry,
don't worry, don't worry.
Just don't worry. You're not supposed to worry.
Just don't worry. Now, are you gonna go out there
and knock it outta the park?
Maybe not, maybe not. But something's gonna come of it.
Something will come of it, I promise you.
And that's how, that's how you grow.
But you're never ever gonna grow.
Just being in one place
telling yourself you can't do something.
Telling yourself you're getting scammed.
Like, it, it, it ain't gonna happen for you.
Do you understand? Do you understand?
And there, and there's a part of me going, there's a part
of me going, why can't I teach 'em what I do?
Why, why can't, why can't they just do what I do?
Why, why It's so easy. I guys, I I got a family.
I run a software company, I got a team,
I'm running another company.
But yet I found, I found the time yesterday
to go freaking crush it with an opportunity.
Think about all the opportunities in the world.
How many, is there any other opportunities out there?
Or is open claw the only
opportunity on the planet right now?
How many opportunities are out there guys?
How many, how many opportunities are out there? How many?
How many? How many? There's so many opportunities.
Every single one of you have a mouth you can talk.
Every single one of you can put yourself on video.
You don't, you don't need that. We don't need that.
That don't matter. We can sit on our couch,
we can shoot a video talking about that opportunity
and throw it up on YouTube.
Oh, but I only got 10 views. So what? Throw up another one.
Oh, but I only got 20 views. So what? Throw up another one.
Throw up another one, throw up another one.
Become known for that. Build a list.
Like, whoa, there's so many opportunities
with marketing, with ai, with crypto, like with trading.
Like, I, I don't know what, I can't keep up with it.
I'm not sleeping because of the opportunities
and now where AI has it
and what we're doing with the newsletter and our software
and whew, it's hard to sleep these days, man.
Is there anybody else having a hard time sleeping?
You wanna know why? 'cause we are alive at a great
time, y'all.
This is a great time to be alive.
It's the greatest time to be alive.
You are at the infant stages of something so incredible.
Is there anybody that that has had that thought that,
you know what, I can jump in, do this shadow training
with Chad, learn how to set up this VPS, learn how
to code this damn thing
and then go to all my business owners
and do all of it for 'em before all the marketing schmucks.
Find out and go out there
and teach people how to do this on the masses.
Is there anybody thinking
that Chad is letting this in on the ground level?
We were the first ones
to start creating skills from the browser.
Nobody else is doing that.
Everybody else is trying to figure out how
to install the damn thing.
We're the first ones. I'm coming to you
with groundbreaking technology that I want you to go
and implement in your own business as fast as you can.
And I want you to go plugging into other businesses as fast
as you can and you'll succeed.
'cause you know why you don't have to do the work anymore.
You just gotta train it. You just gotta train it.
Um, guys, I went over today, I was supposed to go to um,
Connie with InstaCare.
You heard that she already left. She took her daughter.
Hopefully she gets some crickets
'cause poor bam bam over there
doesn't have anything to eat today.
Um, so yeah, I've been a little rough around the house.
I appreciate your guys' prayers and everything.
Uh, I'm gonna keep showing up for you the very best I can.
And uh, for some reason, if I do get sick, uh,
and everybody who's gonna be on that shadow call,
by the way, time to chat.
Lemme know if you're gonna be on the shadow call.
Make sure you get the link, Chad nice.com/open claw.
Whether you're on the call or not.
Make sure you get the guide, okay?
Get the guide if you can hop on the call for two weeks.
Great. Now if I get sick,
I'm gonna have G and PNE take over.
Okay? But I plan on being on those calls
for the next 14 days.
Now we're gonna record the calls.
We're gonna put them inside a course route.
Here's what you can expect.
Yes, we're going to assist you in setting up your VPS.
Yes, we're gonna assist you in, in setting up open clock.
Yes, everything that's in that guide, I want you guys to do.
I I want you to set up your voice automation.
I want you to set up your browser extension.
Uh, I I I want you to set up the right memory.
I want you to learn the commands.
Yeah, all that stuff is a little
technical, but you can do it.
You can do it because we're gonna hold you by the hands.
Alright? If you want a hundred percent success with this,
if you believe in it, then now's the time
to start implementing this stuff.
'cause the opportunity's out there really, really well.
And by the way, you guys should start
posting on your wall too.
You saw what I did? I, I took telegram, I was,
and I just started posting on my wall.
You guys should do the same thing.
My God, look at the skill that I created.
You should do the same thing.
You'll get the attention on your wall. Does that make sense?
The time is now. The opportunity is now. Okay?
So everything that's in the guide,
we're gonna do everything we can
to get this all set up for you as a group.
Okay? Now my team is prepared.
If we need to remote into your VPS
and set things up, we're going to do it.
Is it gonna be a challenge for two weeks? Yes, it will.
But it put me in a box.
I know that this is the most important
technology in my life.
It put me in a box where two weeks I am focused on it. Why?
'cause I have pain members that show up every single day.
That's how we were able to build Sprout.
'cause I put myself in a box
where I had to show up for other people.
So for two weeks, at least two weeks,
we're gonna be here every single day for two weeks.
We're gonna record the sessions.
If it needs to go longer, it will go longer.
If you have an idea
and you don't know how to implement it,
you're gonna be able to ask, okay?
Most of the time you're gonna watch us get frustrated
and train this thing and learn different things.
And you're gonna see real results in real time. Okay?
You're, and then you're gonna be able to walk away
and do it on your own.
You'll be able to do it on the call if you want to, okay?
Um, but also any ideas you have,
I'm gonna do everything I can to get you through it.
And I'm gonna be out there on my wall sharing your success.
And at the same time, I want you to learn
to go out there on your wall
because the opportunity is right
and start sharing it as well.
Does that make sense to you guys? Is everybody getting this?
Probably the people that, uh, recognize this opportunity.
This is, I I just realized what I'm gonna do.
Um, I I want two things to happen.
Number one, yes, I want you to set up this technology.
Number two, yes, I want you to set up the technology
for other people, but right now I want you
to recognize this stuff is super, super hot.
So I want you to make posts on your wall.
And what I will do for everybody
that's in the Shadow program, uh,
I will give you the PowerPoint that I created on Wednesday.
So make sure you go through it so
that you can add your own cover
and you can swap out your slide so
that when you post on your wall,
you can say, I created this guide.
Type in the chat guide if you want it. Is that cool?
Is that cool for you guys?
So best I can do, man.
I don't know how to do anything else here.
That's the best I can do for you. Yeah.
And I'll do everything I can to, to teach you how
to post on your wall or whatever.
Like, it's gonna be guys,
I'm just taking screenshots from my phone, giving it
to myself in Zoom and posting it on Facebook.
That's all, that's all I'm doing.
Uh, I'm, I'm like, Hey, look what Open CLA did.
And I just, people are just looking at the screenshot
and I'm saying comment if you want the guide.
So I'll let you, I'll let you have your own guide.
And it, and it is pretty simple.
It's not, there's one page about me,
but you can create your own about me page, right?
But it, it, it's, it's very simple.
It's just step by step, here's
what Open Claw does, here's who it's for.
And then step number one, you know,
set up your VPS step number two, uh, install open clause.
Step number three, here's your API key, you know,
step number four, add audio.
Like I'll give it to you, I'll give it to you.
It's, it was done in PowerPoint.
You guys can make changes to it. It's your own guide.
Uh, and and that way I want you guys posting your
success as you're doing these things.
Does that make sense to everybody?
Good. Open cloud migrate funnels
and email workflow from ClickFunnels go high level to Mint.
But it probably can. It probably can.
Uh, what happened to the five minutes every
Monday for the Pearson?
Oh crap. Crap, crap, crap.
That's an important one. We gotta do this guys.
All right, we gotta do this.
We gotta, we're gonna do it real quick.
Here's what I want you guys to do.
Gee, I need you to remind me of this.
Yeah, we gotta do this every single week. We gotta do this.
Look, here's the thing guys, if I go to, uh,
let me get back into her newsletter.
Holy crap, how did I forget that?
That's the first thing we need to do.
If I go to app dot letterman ai, okay, let me,
I thought I was logged in, but let me
go back into her account.
There's a lot of changes here.
This is called the Inbox syndicate.
This is really, really important that you guys do this
at least every single week, okay?
You're gonna go to subscribers, actually.
Publication directory. Okay?
Now look, there's 431 publications.
I'm only subscribed to 424.
So I wanna make sure I got my Gmail here.
This Gmail is only for newsletters.
I'm gonna say, show me the ones that are unsubscribed, okay?
Now I'm gonna go ahead and subscribe to this guy.
This guy is this one back? No.
Uh, this guy, this guy, this guy and this guy.
Now I am subscribed to 430. This one has a problem.
Do you guys see that right now? Type the chat.
Let me know if you're doing this. Now,
if I turn this off, here's how this works.
Look here guys. Village Buzz sent out an hour
41 minutes ago.
It's got 94 peers. 37% of them are engaged.
4 0 4 towns sent out two hours and 41 minutes ago.
It's got 33 peers, 24% of the peers are engaged.
The more peers you have
and the more engagement with those peers, the better chances
of you going to the inbox.
Does that make sense to everybody?
Does that make sense? So your
newsletter will go to the number one spot.
It shows the last one sent.
So how many of you're like, oh my God,
I gotta start sending out my newsletter
so I can start getting these peers.
Yes or no? How many of
you're starting to get this right now?
So just send out your newsletter
and it will cycle up here, here to the top.
And by the way, this is the very best chance
to get your newsletters before this platform takes off.
'cause this thing's gonna change every
single time you refresh it.
But right now we only have 431 in this account. Okay?
So this one's sent out two hours, 41 minutes ago, 25%.
Look at 56% of people are engaged,
56% of the peers are engaged, 45% of the peers are engaged.
45%, 46, 43, 41, 42.
Okay, so the question becomes,
and we are showing the top 10 here, okay?
The question becomes how do I get the engagement?
Well, here's the answer.
If we come over here to subscribers,
if we look at the publication, you are going to see
here's all the subscribers.
And what I can do is I can go ahead
and click on Peers, okay?
And from here I can now see the activity.
So right now she has 36% active.
So these are all the active people.
So that means Parkway tells Marco Island Sun,
the Newport Newser, south Base Pulse,
the Serial B City Buzz, New Zealand Biz, hello Brazelton,
Hendersonville Pulse, the Scottsdale Newsletter.
All these people have opened up our newsletter
and here was the last time they opened it up
on a scale of one outta 10.
Does everybody understand this right now?
Okay. So to answer your question, the way
that you're gonna get more activity is just
to simply open up the newsletters in the email
of the people you're subscribed to.
That's it. So what you wanna do,
and what I do is I go to Gmail on my phone,
can we go ahead and do that right now?
Go to Gmail on your phone.
I'm gonna tell you very, very quickly go to
that specific inbox, okay?
So for me it's letterman newsletters@gmail.com
and go to primary
and then just go ahead and open 'em all up.
So I just opened up Seaside Buzz
and I click to see the latest issue.
Alright? So I'm just gonna go through
and I'm gonna do this for all of 'em.
Can you guys do the same thing? Just go to your email.
I'm gonna open up 2 1 9 beat.
Uh, I'm gonna open up the last best post.
I'm gonna open up Village Buzz.
I'm gonna open up Edmonton Buzz.
I'm gonna open up the Blair Buzz
I'm gonna open up the Huron Valley Insider.
I'm gonna open up the Harrison Post. Uh, let's see.
I'm gonna open up, uh, think act locally.
I'm gonna open up Pulson perspective.
I'm gonna open up Oak Lawn Beacon.
The Madison Memo, river Valley Local,
Woodward Shoutouts, Marvin Gza,
round Rock, shoutouts, Cambridge,
spotlight Porter.
More Morales Insider Zoo Town, lowdown,
north Port Matters.
Port Charlotte Matters. Uh, hello or Ellington Weekly.
Are you guys doing this right now? Irvington Pulse.
Dala Sizzle, Broadwalk, broad
Broadwalk Beat Newsletter.
Palm Coast Insider Bay Breeze Bulletin.
Newport Newser, Cedar City Insider, Scottsdale Local.
Okay, and now I'm gonna go to spam
and I'm gonna look at anything in Spam.
Diamond District Standard. I'm gonna say not spam.
Uh, Craig, Anthony, chaos in Atlanta, not Spam. St.
George Thrives. Insider, not spam.
Cedar City Insider, not Spam. St. George Thrives.
Insider, not spam. Chip Valley Bites not spam.
Uh, south Southland Signal not spam.
And the Brunswick Beaches beat not spam.
The last thing I need to do is go to promotions. Ed Munchie.
I'm gonna open that up. Craig
Anthony, I'm gonna open that up.
That's the Orlando or Tater az,
Florence News Insider opening up Port Charlotte Matters.
Opening up Gym City Flyer, opening up Mountain
to Message Journal, opening up Rochester Life
and Times Open up Northport Matters.
Open up South Sound Life. Open up. Ed Munchie. Open up.
And that's it. I need you guys to do this every single day.
That's it. Does everybody got it?
Scale of one outta 10, does everybody get it now,
scale of one outta 10, does everybody get it?
Several people do not have their reply email set.
And when we comment, it gets returned undeliverable.
You might wanna show people
why they might have that problem.
If you go through the Hustle
2.0 training, I talk about that.
Um, you want to at least put a Gmail there
so your reply email goes to your Gmail
and you're able to respond back at least.
Um, I think we showed how to do it with name cheap.
If we didn't, uh, I'll shoot that video for you guys.
But you wanna set up an actual email
where you can reply back to people.
Okay, so that's a good catch, Jim.
Um, the 9 4 6 B is having a problem attempting to subscribe.
Yeah, I saw that James. They're working on that.
Um, but now when you go to your subscribers,
you guys can look at your actives, you can look at your,
uh, active clickers.
You can look at, at the people that are inactive.
So guess what you could do?
You could reach out to Wood Sprite,
you could reach out to capital City B.
You could reach out to Life Boulder Valley.
You could reach out to Newcomer Digest
and say, Hey, uh, I like your newsletter.
I'm clicking. Can you do me a favor and click on mine?
The people that are inactive, you can get them back.
The people are passive. They were never
green, but they're in the red.
Okay? You can reach out to all these people
and then you've got people that are over here dead.
Let's see if any dead people are on the call,
that means you have not opened my newsletter in 30 days
plus 45 days.
So the Medicine Ball Authority, uh,
the Clarksville Scoop try, Scottsdale Insider 8 0 1 Insider,
Maplewood Shoutouts,
the Space Coast Spotlight, Java Spotlight.
All of these people, uh, I can reach out to
because they put their publication there.
These other people, I can send an email if I want to.
Guys, this is the secret. This is the inbox syndicate.
This is how we get to the inbox.
Does that make sense to everybody?
Chad, if I right click on the line item in your promo
folder, you can choose to move the email to regular.
I tried that. It doesn't work for me.
I think somewhere in promotions, guys,
you can right click on it and tell it to go to the inbox,
but it, it is not working for me.
So if you guys know how to do that, try
to take your promotions and
and send it to your, your inbox folder, right?
All I have is move to pri. Oh, there it is. Move to primary.
You're right, it wasn't there before.
So Craig, Anthony, move to primary.
So we can go into the promotions. Port Charlotte matters.
Click on those dots. Move to primary.
I couldn't, you know what? I
couldn't do it from the desktop.
Uh, let's see. Gym City flyer, move to primary,
uh, mountain Mess Journal.
Move to primary. I'm gonna
tell you something else too, guys.
And this is the reason why I'm excited to have,
um, Pacino on board.
This was the first Monday of the week.
We should have done our free backlinks today too,
but we were so excited with Open Claw.
We're gonna do free backlinks on Monday.
This, this upcoming Monday. The next newsletter call.
We will do the free backlinks to make up for it.
Northport matters. Move to primary.
Is everybody able to do this?
Good.
Um, perfect.
Okay, good. So open and click.
If you can just do it every day,
just take five minutes and just do that.
If you do that, more people are gonna open your newsletter.
Does that make sense? By the way,
is this an ongoing thing guys?
Guys? Is this an ongoing thing? Yeah.
Yeah man, I want you
to go into the inbox When you mail your actual subscribers
in your backyard and those business
owners, I want you to go in the inbox.
That's why we have this inbox syndicate.
That's why we have it. It's an ongoing thing.
Take five minutes, open up the email, open
and click the ones in the inbox.
Go to promotions. Click on those little dots up there.
Say move to primary. Okay, Google's watching all this.
You're telling Google, this is a really,
really important newsletter.
They're watching everything you're doing.
And then go over to your, um,
spam and mark.
It is not spam. Make sense?
How many of you got that done today?
And you're right, we will take five minutes every Monday.
It's important that we do that.
So whoever reminded me, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I appreciate it. Alright, um,
guys, I need to meet with the team.
I gotta help the family today.
Uh, if you didn't get the guide chat.com/claw, um,
as soon as you get signed up for the uh, shadow program,
we will send you your Zoom access.
I think I'm gonna put everybody in a WhatsApp group
that is participating with that.
We're either gonna do the call at 10:00 AM Pacific Standard
time or 2:00 PM Pacific Standard time,
depending on if we have calls or not.
Okay? So I'll keep everybody posted in the group.
Like I said, I will record all the replays and everything.
It's gonna be great. And, uh, I think moving forward,
because, uh, my team
and the new team that's coming on board, uh,
because we're gonna be so far advanced of everybody else,
that we'll probably have a shadow program every single time
there's some new strategy, some new technology
where you guys can just watch us figure everything out,
and then you're able to do it yourself
and then you're able to take that opportunity out there,
go out there on your wall and uh, go do it for other people.
All. Chad,
we're changing the dates in the article XML file cause
of duplicate SI don't know.
I don't know, Jim, I'll get with you on that.
It's a little bit of a struggle for us right now,
but we'll figure something out.
Alright everybody, let me just check in scale of one to 10,
did you get a lot of value on the call?
Sorry about all the preaching today,
but sometimes I guess it's necessary,
but do we get a lot of value on the call?
10 10 10 10 10, 10. 10. 110 10. 10. 10. Yes.
10, 10. 10. 10, 10. Good, good.
Uh, Tom, did you get a lot of value on the call today? Tom?
I want, I I I honestly want you to crush it out.
Tom, I want you to crush it out. Steve. Timon 10. Braten.
Katherine? 10. David 10 Braten, Dan.
Okay, good, good, good, good guys, thank you so much.
I hope you have a great week Mastermind members.
Be ready on Wednesday. We got a lot to do
and, uh, everybody that joined the Shadow program,
I'll see you Wednesday morning,
10:00 AM Pacific Standard Time.
Alright, bye everybody.